[Music]
growing up we had a lot of conflict I
did not like her until she was well how
old were you when you went to run 21
tell she was 21 she was an angry one no
your she's the angry one I'm the passive
one yeah I have never been in a physical
fight beside pulling her hair and poking
her eyeing her I've been in a physical
fight it's usually like if a guy says
something to me and like punch him but
then he's like oh you're a girl I'm not
gonna punch you back so like that's how
these people are trophy men that means
I'm allergic and I picked him up by a
shirt and I flew him down see aggressive
anybody's frustrating anybody I'm
probably frustrating here but I would
get frustrated so that's this true I
think we're playing a game that will
help me not hate her all the time
oh my god I'm so nervous
what this thing good job you copy
Bobby go ahead I love it this is huge
arm extension I'm gonna assume it's some
sort of punching for sure yeah it really
hurts like please don't punch me in the
face I'm gonna win no you're not that we
purposely put the black and what it was
so what do you look at the size of this
guy's helmets oh my god we don't have it
we got this little headband and they
have a full gear headgear in this photo
oh my god
oh you joke good joke at me how do you
feel safe like that that's right what
that's smart as her words oh my god wait
do you feel safe enough yeah but I can't
hear you don't need to hear I'm gonna
punch you I hope you go home like that
to your husband is gonna what this is
good more it isn't gonna where he died
there's a different level of infinite
yeah there this is like years of like
aggressive in taking out right now I
don't want to hurt I'm not gonna hurt
you either okay okay sorry
what does it bro okay whatever I'm
hustling one minute one minute exercise
no I'm very dense did I weigh I
definitely feel like this would be a
bonding experience we wouldn't do this
normally there's a slightly like weird
sexual innuendo this thing yeah you know
definitely resolved some of our
conflicts in our life because nothing
resolves conflicts like a peanut sort of
the base ice cream solves any issues so
you got a problem just get some ice
cream
then you won't have any problems anymore
[Music]